el experimento de la doble ranura de
jong lucía como esto tenemos una barrera
con dos agujeros pero esos agujeros son
tan pequeños y están tan juntos que los
describimos como ranuras es doble porque
hay dos de estos yo no fue un físico
inglés a quien se le ocurrió por primera
vez realizar un experimento de este tipo
lo que hacemos es tomar un láser y lo
dirigimos hacia la doble ranura ahora la
luz del láser tiene que ser lo
suficientemente ancha como para que
llegue a ambas ranuras quizás ustedes
piensen que necesitamos un láser grande
pero no es así ambas ranuras las ponemos
muy juntitas esta es una de las razones
la otra razón es que la distancia entre
ambos agujeros tiene que ser comparable
no necesariamente idéntico o más pequeño
pero tiene que ser parecido al tamaño de
esta onda no puede ser mucho mayor que
la longitud de onda de esta onda de otra
forma no veremos el interesante patrón
que se va a dar con esta configuración y
ustedes se preguntarán bueno que estoy
dibujar
aquí qué es esto esto no es una onda
esto sí es una onda al menos así es como
las conocemos pero aquí tenemos una
representación diferente y la razón de
esto es que cuando dibujo esto me
permite mostrar una onda en una
dimensión pero esto no es suficiente
pues nuestro proceso va a ser
fundamentalmente en dos dimensiones por
lo que no puedo dibujarlo así esta línea
de acá representa un pico de la onda
todos estos son picos de las ondas
pueden imaginarse esta onda llenando
toda esta región estas líneas
representan aquella parte de la onda en
donde hay un pico que hay a la mitad de
esto pues tendremos la parte más baja de
la onda su valle y eso es lo que vamos a
usar vamos a usar esta representación de
una onda para mostrar cómo se esparce
esta onda en dos dimensiones que sucede
pues esta onda se acerca esta parte toca
la barrera y no la puede atravesar esta
parte toca la barrera y tampoco la
atraviesa la única parte de la onda que
y pasar por la barrera es estar aquí y
esta otra de acá estas son las únicas
que van a poder pasar la barrera
y qué es lo que veremos en la pared de
acá pueden imaginarse que es una
pantalla en donde se proyecta la luz que
es lo que veremos bueno en un primer
momento nos podríamos imaginar que ya
que la luz pasa por acá tendremos aquí
un punto brillante y como la luz también
pasa por acá
aquí habrá otro punto brillante o lo que
tendremos solo dos puntos con los pero
esto no es así y esa es la razón por la
que este experimento es tan interesante
ya que no obtendremos dos puntos
brillantes tendremos un patrón aquí
porque las ondas no van a pasar en línea
recta a través de este agujero siempre
que se encuentra en un agujero o alguna
esquina se van a propagar y a esto le
llamamos difracción tendremos una onda
que se va a propagar por acá no va a ir
en línea recta se va a propagar en dos
dimensiones por eso tengo que usar este
dibujo de onda para ilustrar esto y cómo
se van a propagar desde ambos agujeros
que es lo que tenemos aquí
chispas se están sobreponiendo estas
ondas se van atrás la par y en donde se
traslapan de manera constructiva
tendremos un punto brillante y en donde
se traslapan de forma destructiva
tendremos un punto de oscuridad así que
más o menos la mitad será constructivo y
la otra mitad será destructivo por lo
que quizás tendremos un punto
medianamente brillante como es que va a
resultar este patrón bueno no puedo
dibujar esto lo suficientemente preciso
por lo que permítanme quitar todo esto y
en el agujero de abajo vamos a tener
esto un bonito patrón esférico que va a
salir de acá y quizás no tenga la misma
intensidad de acá pero no puedo
dibujarlo con la intensidad exacta la
intensidad de lo que pase por el agujero
de arriba será un poquito menor que el
de aquí abajo pero esa es la forma en
cómo visualizamos su distribución
ambas ondas se esparcen tanto en el
agujero de abajo como en el agujero de
arriba y ahora se van atrás la par aquí
están las dos las ondas que se traslapan
en la misma región
interferencia constructiva y destructiva
y si se fijan recuerden que estas líneas
representan los picos así que cada vez
que un pico se alinea con otro pico o en
la parte de en medio un valle con otro
valle cada vez que la onda esté en fase
exacta al llegar a este mismo punto
tendremos interferencia constructiva así
que justo en el medio tendremos un punto
muy brillante lo que es bastante extraño
justo en medio de estos agujeros
tendremos un punto muy brillante que más
bueno fíjense en esto
esto es constructivo constructivo todas
estas son constructivas y forman una
línea una línea de pura interferencia
constructiva lo mismo esto es
constructivo constructivo todas estas
reformas otra línea de interferencia
constructiva así que en la pantalla
tendremos varios puntos brillantes todas
estas son constructivas porque los picos
se están alineando perfectamente aquí
tengo otro y vamos a tener todos estos
puntos brillantes en la pared no van a
durar para siempre
es decir en algún punto se van a
desvanece
y van a ser difíciles de ver veremos
algunos puntos muy brillantes por el
medio pero hacia los extremos van a ir
disminuyendo hasta que ya casi no nos
podamos ver y en el medio en cualquier
punto en donde un pico se alinee con un
valle esto es un pico pero para la otra
onda está justo en medio es un valle en
este punto tenemos interferencia
destructiva ya que un pico está
coincidiendo con un valle esto será
destructivo esto también así que aquí en
medio tendremos puntos destructivos aquí
tendremos lo mismo una interferencia
destructiva entre estos puntos
perfectamente alineados
entre estos tendremos puntos que son la
mitad constructivo y la mitad
destructivo se van a unir y lo que vamos
a tener es algo que los físicos les
gusta representar de forma gráfica
tendremos un punto muy brillante en el
medio esta gráfica representa la
intensidad del brillo de los puntos
tenemos un punto brillante va hacia cero
tenemos otro punto brillante y de nuevo
bajamos a cero y tenemos otro punto aquí
conforme nos vamos alejando del centro
se van a ser más débiles estos puntos
hasta que llegará un momento en el que
no los podamos ver lo mismo de este lado
cero punto brillante cero punto
brillante este es el patrón clásico del
experimento de doble ranura de jong es
lo que vemos en la pared y es ocasionado
por la interferencia entre las ondas en
dos dimensiones cual es la regla de
interferencia de ondas en dos
dimensiones es la misma regla que la
interferencia de ondas en una dimensión
es esta recuerden cuando vimos el caso
de una dimensión delta x la diferencia
entre la longitud de la ruta tiene que
ser cero
2 lambda 3 lambda y así sucesivamente
todos estos nos darán interferencia
constructiva y si pusieron atención me
pueden decir a ver un momento aquí había
una condición esto se cumplía si no
había ninguna cuestión extraña con la
parte de atrás de la bocina tenemos que
asegurarnos que ambas fuentes estén en
fase desde el inicio y esto también se
cumple para estas longitudes de onda y
es por eso que hacemos la doble ranura
tomamos una onda y esa onda pasa por
aquí y se va a descomponer en dos partes
porque pues porque sí sabemos que un
pico está pasando por el agujero de
arriba tendremos la misma onda que pasa
por el agujero de abajo y también
tendremos un pico al mismo tiempo esta
es una forma rápida y sencilla de
asegurarnos de que ambas fuentes que
pasan por estos dos agujeros están en
fase exacta no tendremos que
preocuparnos por alguna diferencia de
fase causada por una de las fuentes sólo
tendremos que preocuparnos por el hecho
de que estas sondas van a tener que
viajar
distancias a diferentes puntos a qué me
refiero con esto esta diferencia de
longitud del recorrido aquí si yo la veo
desde esta línea de arriba o de este
agujero de arriba que se parecen a
nuestras bocinas una fuente aquí y otra
fuente acá pero tenemos luz en lugar de
ondas de sonido de aquí al centro hay un
punto brillante la onda de la parte de
arriba tiene que recorrer cierta
distancia y del agujero de abajo hasta
acá la onda también tuvo que viajar
cierta distancia básicamente a esto le
llamamos x1 esta longitud es x2 y la
diferencia en la longitud de las rutas
serán x1 menos x2 es la diferencia entre
estas y podríamos tomar el valor
absoluto pero el tamaño de la diferencia
entre estas dos longitudes de ruta justo
en el centro cuál será puede ser a delta
x igual a 0 ya que ambas ondas están
viajando la misma distancia para llegar
a este punto eso tiene sentido es un
punto constructivo ya que 0 nos da una
interferencia constructiva esto lo
tendremos cuando la diferencia entre las
longitudes de ruta sea igual a cero qué
pasa con el siguiente punto bueno
la onda de abajo tiene que viajar así de
lejos y la onda de arriba tiene que
viajar esta distancia en este caso a las
zonas no están recorriendo la misma
distancia la onda de abajo tiene que
recorrer más distancia cuanto más lejos
pues tiene que ser la siguiente tiene
que ser lambda la onda de abajo va a
tener que estar viajando una longitud de
onda más que la onda de arriba ya que es
la siguiente posibilidad para la
interferencia constructiva noten que no
es de aquí acá y este es un error común
esta distancia entre dos puntos
constructivos no es una longitud de onda
es la diferencia entre la longitud de la
ruta que una de las ondas tiene que
recorrer en comparación de la otra eso
es una longitud de onda y yo creo que
ustedes ya adivinaron cuál es la
siguiente la siguiente va a ser delta x
igual a 2 lambda y podemos continuar de
esta manera qué va a pasar con los
puntos destructivos bueno sabemos cómo
hacer esto va a ser la mitad de la
longitud de onda este va a ser lambda
entre 2 éste va a ser 3 lambda / 2
y así sucesivamente aquí abajo lo que
vamos a tener es que si nos deshacemos
del símbolo de valor absoluto veremos
que está delta x va a ser igual a menos
un lambda este será menos 2 lambda y así
sucesivamente así que podremos tener
valores negativos
si queremos notar el hecho de
diferenciar los puntos más bajos de los
más altos dependiendo del patrón de
interferencia